well another mountain lion spotted in
the valley over the weekend this time in
the northwest part of the valley
very close to the mountains out at the
beautiful floyd land park
and that's where sally caramillo joins
us now live sally understand that they
were
able to safely capture that animal yes
denise on saturday the mountain lion was
located right here at the mancy's home
and it was that particular corner where
it was tranquilized and then returned to
its habitat
according to the department of wildlife
these sightings are not uncommon we
really have no way of quantifying
exactly how many different lions have
been seen
it's the tacos of town when a mountain
lion is spotted unfortunately
doug nielsen with the department of
wildlife does not know if this is the
same mountain lion captured
multiple times despite the wildcat scene
on many home surveillance cameras
this activity of wildlife interacting
with us has been around
for a long time it does happen some
years we
have had more sightings than others any
lions from previous birth years that are
have now reached adulthood they get
booted out of the nest
so they have to find a territory that's
unoccupied as for juvenile mountain
lions walking around neighborhoods
nielsen says they're just
wondering this sighting happened in
february
it seems to be associated with the
spring mountain range
which has elk population deer
bighorn sheep as well as a
horse population on saturday gary gibson
sought one for the first time
in his northwest neighborhood it was
just weird to see him you know
you don't see him every day that's all
gibson recalls i saw a bunch of cop cars
and then they had animal control three
three trucks
we couldn't actually talk to each other
because the police were here and they
wanted us inside because las vegas has
grown so fast
is this a wildlife human interaction at
what we call the wildland
interface our development and the
wildlands meet together
and there's a lot of interaction between
human beings and wildlife at that
junction
whether it's squirrels and rabbits or
it's coyotes and bobcats or the
occasional mountain way
now if you have pets make sure you
supervise them at all times
especially at night and if you spot a
mountain lion in your neighborhood
call authorities immediately reporting
live sally jaramillo 8 news now